thank you for the kind introduction um
so i'm gonna be talking uh
very little about docker itself and more
about where we're gonna go
uh from here i guess
all of you know what docker is
yes
everyone's looking not in that stage so
that's awesome um
so uh
those of you um some of you who are
familiar with the history but joshua is
just over a year old
um i think it i think it's uh i think
it's slightly younger than digital ocean
but only just um
and it was open source in march last
year and our version one release was in
the start at the start of june
so
uh in less than a year and a bit we've
gone from um uh sort of a hacky
prototype you know a language that most
of us know very well go into an act is
something we consider reasonably
production ready and solid
um as part of that process we identified
a whole lot of things that really we we
needed to do beyond docker so don't go
very much handles the sort of compute
side of things and uh
when we started to sit down and go well
you know we built this really cool
container virtualization thing and it
does you know we build containers and
build images you can do all this sort of
stuff to sort of manage the basics of
your build pipeline we started to think
about well what do you need to actually
make this a full new face production
tool
okay so what do we do now um this is uh
this is a lion solomon uses all the time
to me which is like which is generally
speaking as if we hadn't built anything
over the last 12 months and we're just
scratching the surface
which gives you an indication of how
solomon's brain works so
he describes what we have as a blueprint
um it's sort of like a a methodology
with a bit of tooling around it that
says you know in order to
ship applications around and be portable
you know you have containers you have a
workflow the docker provides have a
strong platform and strong api
so
where do we go from here well the next
logical step is that um you know the
problem we were originally trying to
solve is kind of the problem a little
bit that has in the ice markets trying
to solve which is that it's kind of hard
to get code off your desktop and stick
it somewhere and run it
like there's lots of different solutions
you can go with stuff like heroku and
biophantom openstack and amazon but all
of them require sort of varying levels
of complexity and it's pretty hard if
you've chosen heroku it's pretty hard to
make a decision i'm going to back out of
that and go to amazon or at least it's a
non-trivial exercise
so we sat down and said there is
actually a uh
you know there's actually a bigger
problem here and it's that in order for
more complex applications more
applications from let's say one or two
containers to be actually managed we
need to have a whole bunch of tooling
around that that makes that possible
so this is again time to upgrade the
internet
this is our very own
so very
well described as modest claim
so
we have the technology
um
there's a bunch of stuff out there
people have demonstrated awesome stuff
with docker and without
uh we have heaps of bandwidth storage is
really easy compute
you get some sandboxing there's crypto
tools out there compression
uh copy and right file systems packs and
raft consensus there's a whole bunch of
these little things out there um
but
all of them tend to be sort of pulled
together in different ways so
a good example of this is uh if you work
at a really smart shop like stuff like
docker was not a surprise to you like if
you work in etsy they've been an lxc
user for
several years you work at google two
million containers a week
but etsy google flickr
ebay facebook all the other places that
were sort of heavy container shops all
had something in common they had a bunch
of really smart engineers who built the
standard interfaces for tools like lxd
and they put them together and they made
them into work in their environment if
you talked to any of those engineers and
i was talking about facebook the other
day
um about like why didn't you guys open
source that and he goes well
hmm what's kind of tricky and it's sort
of tied to our environment and it's hard
to use awesome stuff but i said so
there's no real api and it goes what's
an api but it's sort of a facebook api
and i'm like okay all right um by that
it means it's like that every one of the
facebook engineers recognize that you
have to sort of read you get to actually
make it work
so we've got all this cool technology
don't have any standard interfaces so
docker um one of the big things about
docker is we attempt to build standard
interfaces so the first thing we sat
down with and said is you know let's
stop using lsc and there's a couple
reasons we did that one of them is that
lxe is um
uh you know very obviously very linux
centric and occasionally a little bit
not very backwards compatible
and a little bit unstable and we said to
ourselves
you know
what what can we do about changing this
and what we came up with is something
called lip container and we realized as
part of that discussion that
the value of docker is not really the
technology it's getting people to agree
on what you describe as a standard um
and i very much uh
i i've worked in the linux unix world
for 20 something odd years
and you can really find people who will
agree about package formats and init
systems and things like that and we
looked at that and said how about we
actually actually bypass a lot of this
discussion take this the next level up
and actually try and have a conversation
about standardizing compute and
portability things around compute
so we already have the packaging
distribution which is the container
itself
um
we have simple sandboxing which is uh
and uh this is a uh
it's the cat the cat running around
inside the thing not causing any harm
because it's safely inside a doctor
container not sure whether there was a
whole burner heisenberg
uncertainty principle i think at work
here or not but um uh and i'm sure they
let the cat afterwards um but we had
this format we called the container and
libertainer essentially is what we
replaced lxc with it and it's basically
a standard interface to operating system
sandboxing
and it combines all of the capabilities
we use name spaces and c groups lots of
stuff
um and as part of the docker 1.0 launch
we pulled it out of docker itself i've
got the core and we made it a separate
project
and you can see it here
um we embed lip retainer and so
documents you'll get it but it's now a
standalone project and you're probably
going that's already using like
container formats like this is for
incoming stuff but these are the people
we've got to agree that this is a good
idea
so red hat this contribute has
contributed selenium support and systemd
integration
so now lip container you can actually
use lip container on its own natively
out of the box as red hat
with a bunch of tweaks
uh google have recently joined they're
emerging there they have a format called
let me let me containerize this object
i get hung tight every time i say i
don't know there's some lmtcp whatever
um so they're joining us commentators
and they're going to actually
standardize on loop container
those of you who work in service
providers will be familiar with these
guys pretty much anyone running a vps
environment it's probably going to open
vz running somewhere they're considering
a c implementation which will link to
openvz
uh
the lxc and ubuntu guys are also going
to be providing a c group interface so
what we're attempting to do is
essentially say let's produce a standard
that says here we have containers
these are just the people i can talk
about now um hypothetically there is a
large software firm in redmond
that they may be interested in
contributing something like hyper-v
support where type of v is kind of just
like operating system virtualization
very easy to add to a live container
format uh as is several other um
software companies who have a similar
sort of thing including
uh things like solaris zones
uh bsd jails and similar sorts of things
which means that we'll be able to say
doesn't matter what the platform is you
get the same portability
from a container
your work sorry
yeah solaris is our oracle obviously
oracle product we're having a
conversation with them about uh so
both solaris and also um i always say
that's wrong with luminos or whatever
it's called the the open solaris
thingy um
cs you can see that the repo if you are
interested in this sort of technology um
there's a great opportunity to to get
involved
one of the other things dockers provides
is networking
but that current networking is really
simple like it's if you have a single
docker host the containers on that host
can talk to one another but they can't
talk to other docker containers and
other docker hosts which kind of limits
the capabilities so like you can build
multi-tier multi-stack containers but
they have to live in one place and
that's kind of like
and we all know that our applications
don't live in one place either
so we've open sourced another project
called libchan
um which is a communication protocol for
distributed systems and essentially what
it is is it it relies on
very much like go channels for those who
commute with it over the network does
simple message passing a synchronization
passes everything around as raw sockets
and does nesting so you can actually
build things like nested channels of
communication
we're going to make this the backbone of
the communication between
between docker and other docker hosts
and other other bits of infrastructure
as well
it's a really simple bit of technology
it's very easy to write a lip chain
interface it's like a you know 40 50
lines of code incredibly simple
uh it natively supports spdy and tls
websockets or tcp unix sockets and imago
channels
so already out of the box we're trying
to take things a bit further and say
technology is moving we should actually
think ahead of it instead of trying to
support just support what's in the past
it's secure by default so it actually it
defaults to a state of trying to use tls
so you can actually use it you know as a
communication layer
and we're making our standard sort of
communication layout for docker and all
basically the internal components of
docker
um
things like uh the current container
communication things like that will be
replaced with this
um it's open source you can go and have
a look you can use it um it's very
simple right now but it's been grown
upon all the time
so that's really kind of a building
block again not hugely exciting which
leads us into the piece that i'm
actually kind of interested in because
this is the part where we actually start
to sort of put
the uh
um
our money where our mouth is and that is
that if you're trying to build things
like
multi multi-tenant multi uh site
applications you really need to have
some sort of sense of orchestration and
so what we've done is we've said
we've got a standard format which is the
docker api
we're going to make the docker api talk
across multiple docker hosts so you can
have a docker host in aws have a docker
host in your vmware cluster behind the
firewall you know the docker hosted
digitalocean
um
and you're gonna be able to ship
containers around
and we don't really care what the
shipping is not particularly fast um
lib channel is gonna be the layer of
communication um you can use we're gonna
make this plugable so you can use
whatever tools you like
uh for example if you like mesos choose
main sauce have amazon stool let's share
drilling and shipping move your
containers around like maison says it's
four o'clock in the afternoon i get
cheap spot rates on amazon i'm gonna
move all my stuff to amazon
it's the weekend it's cheaper digital
it's gonna move it back there
um
or giddy or core os or fleet don't
really care i think there's some awesome
tools an ecosystem being developed out
there
um i i i love ecosystem competition
orchestration tools have been one of
those spaces where things have sucked
for a very long time so you have like
four or five tools you're just like oh
this is awesome um
and then
or console or helios or new relics new
centurion again the ecosystem this is
most of these tools have appeared in the
last six months if not the last three
months given an indication of where we
might be in 12 months time is is a
hugely interesting ecosystem
so
and i haven't got the inflation on now
oops
and he's going to kill me there we go
so
we have we have a bunch of different
fabrics you can deploy to um including
things like lego
uh pretty much anything that you can run
a docker host on now we should be able
to target
and then
we're gonna provide an orchestration
layer and we call this orchestration
layer live swarm
and i can't again this is one of those
things that i pronounce funny americans
apparently hear this as but it's like a
swarm of wasps and everyone looks at me
and goes what a swarm no swarm swarm
i'll try
um and it's basically a very little
simple toolkit at the moment it's very
difficult basically for composing
network services
so what we're going to produce is that
it's essentially a way of saying
here's here's the service and here's the
service a bunch of capabilities and
components about that service
that i want to share with other services
and it's a standard way to advertise
that
so you can compose relatively complex
architecture support building blocks
you can swap any service like you know
you don't like the authentication
service you're using
a good example here is you're an awk
shop and you're currently plugged into
an aws service like rds
it's very easy to build a standard
interface to ies and then say ah it's
not like ids anymore i'd like to skip to
something else a native mysql database
on my local environment i'll flip the
interface to say point to the mysql
database obviously
early days
not quite as easy as that yet say for a
database but it's very easy to swap in
and out of the new resource i can easily
build an interface that talks to amazon
and ec2 and spins up an instance if i
don't like that anymore i can i can flip
it and point it to the do's api and spin
up an instance there instead and migrate
my workload all completely transparent
um we're gonna have a built-in library
of things people are currently riding
uh the aws team a bunch of other people
are currently writing services um
yeah so there's our mesos client atomic
and yeti fleet pcd orchard google cloud
rackspace diode 2d ship guard tls tunnel
adapter
ibm have a
soft soft layer adapter there's a bunch
of other tools incoming
essentially what we allow you to say
um
you know
i can have all of my my docker servers
communicate over this media
at the moment it's very simple and it
literally was open source two weeks ago
but if you have a look at um
if you have a look at the repo you've
got to see what we're working on and the
one thing we guarantee is that lip swarm
will always work on docker so if you
have lip swarm in the middle there
then we will guarantee that that lip
swarm will always allow you to
communicate between a docker host
another dog host
that's the repo there
and you can have it have a visit that as
i said it's very early days we've only
started to see that
come out of the woodwork but we expect
to have some big product releases around
this in the next couple of months
so those are the kind of the the sort of
building block pieces and and i do
apologize because they are very much
building block pieces for a lot of
people this is like this is not exciting
he's talking about widgets i can't use a
widget
but we have some other things on the way
that build on these widgets
so
one of the problems a lot of people have
is that when they run docker images
they're worried about the fact that
where did this document come from we
have a little bit of transparency to
that you can see how a docker image is
built from the dockerfile and we have
uh automated builds that allow you to
sort of link your docker the docker hub
to github and build things
but we're also going to add
identity so you can actually sign docker
images you've got to say
either with an internal ca or a ca
available to you to be able to say this
docker image belongs to
me and my company and i can guarantee
that it's produced by say the the
production operations team and they're
going to ship that and if
you imagine a lot of other people
we uh ship images with us people like
red hat
um oracle and people like that are very
keen to be able to say
this docker image is the oracle
mysql.com this docker image is the rel7
image that comes from red hat and you'd
be able to run that to the image and say
is this a valid image with a science
certificate
this can lead to a couple of other
interesting things
the primary one being authorization you
do stuff like i will only let my docker
hosts run a valid rail image
for example
you know i'm entitled to 100 rail
licenses and they all must come from the
red hat image and that's all it can run
on that particular machine or
this is the production docker host it'll
only run images
signed by the productions which means
you can say someone builds a stray image
or you can't launch a container from
that image you will only be able to
launch a container from an authorized
and for a lot of people with big
environments this is a really critical
sort of step so this is something
working right now and we should have
some design stuff for this in public in
the next month or so
and i already heard from several people
but i need it now um
come talk to us if you have a
requirement for this if your shop is
actually interested in this as a concept
i'm happy to take design input and put
you in touch with the team is actually
working on this
um
that's probably the the
the next big things in the uh
uh in the uh in the yard there i do like
these kind of things um
but
you'll see a bunch more things from us
to expand the docker hub there's a bunch
of services on that now there'll be a
bunch more things coming in q3
uh in q4
we will allow you to sort of run your
own docker hub behind the firewall in
sort of hybrid sort of mode and q1 next
year you'll be able to actually buy
something that looks like the docker hub
internally um which should be a pretty
cool concept um
can you just expand on docker hub and
what it does sure so docker harvest is a
like a central repository for docker
images so currently we run docker hub in
the cloud and uh it provides a
bunch of services like you can push to
it and store your images there
you also have the concept of private
repositories you can actually store
private images on the hub currently but
you can't store them behind your
firewall without with um you know
without a little bit of fiddly stuff so
we can actually make that available for
those people that will not that want to
actually run
all of that hosting i guess you think
about github enterprise your docker
images behind the firewall
all it is is storage simple storage the
current proper registry docker hub has a
bunch of services on top of that
yes that's one of the things that that
sort of will be docker 1.1 probably will
we make document more plugable so you
can actually build stuff so that sort of
standard apis things like the luger
swarm stuff and turn stuff will all be
built on
sort of plugging hooks built into the
docker so if you want to do a variant or
something like that that manages to
contain a particular way or
does logging or hooks into nagios or
whatever it happens to be you should be
relatively easy to build
questions comments
board senseless
so general architecture question how
does docker fit into the environment of
uh cloud cloud foundry or open stack um
those kind of things sure so um uh those
who community with cloud foundry
probably warden is the most
sort of similar sort of tool ibm is in
the process of rewriting warden um with
a thing called decker which is a
basically docker
essentially you'll be able um use part
change of your launch docker compute
excesses
the same thing exists for openstack so
you can use docker in two ways in
openstack one is you can have a driver
for nova that launches stock for
containers instead of virtual machines
or whatever happens to be and you can
also use docker wiki open stacks
orchestration tool to actually launch
containers and do orchestration and
stuff like that
but container is the
delivery
is there a way i know
uh
there is um sort of two different ways
one is you can actually specify when you
run a dot container that it should only
run and exist for the period of the time
the process inside it runs for and then
if it stops when that project stops
it'll stop and delete the container and
that's the dash dash rm option
there's also a currently a pull request
to update that option to say
to update
docker run to say please run this
container for until the process stops
running or for five minutes or for 10
minutes or something like that
i don't quite get the use case but but
okay
already i think so yeah you have to have
a look i i'm pretty sure i saw that
swing by a couple days ago
if not um in the docker dev channel
you're welcome to ping
so what's the roadmap for running docker
as
for running containers as a non-root
user so for example username spaces are
obviously not quite mature in the kernel
yet
but uh aaron tell me some wedding screen
i don't know about anybody
but uh
so given that
i don't want my container to have free
access to my host
is there
so um i'll be really really really
really glad because containers do not
contain if you run root processors
inside you are doing operating system
level virtualization if you have root
processors inside a container you may as
well be just you punch holes in the wall
right
so we recommend really strongly that you
don't run things as root processors
the two things we are doing is that we
are going to mature user name spaces
even if we do it ourselves and they'll
be implemented in docker in one of the
next couple of releases
we also recommend you run docker with se
linux or app armor uh if you're gonna
run stuff that sort of potentially has
the penetrate the opportunity to
penetrate outside that container but
most importantly we say don't run root
processors inside containers not if you
expect any sort of security if you are
going to do that then you should treat
that host as being a separate either
just have a trust zone stick it in a dmz
assume that that host has the potential
to be compromised sure i don't think
that's a bad practice generally running
visa root is kind of a bad idea
horrible idea
power comes great responsibility right
now
but i mean you have to actually
run something as a root process
sometimes i'm dropping doctor just don't
you know
we're adding a warning for the privilege
mode which is the mode that sort of
disables a bunch of that stuff but also
you know similar sort of things you are
doing something that we don't recommend
that's all we can do
there are simply not enough controls yet
i don't know google recently released
this kubernetes
yeah how does that relate to um
the docker swarm is it all related uh it
is um so where i mentioned before that
there were some orchestration tools like
centurion and
helios and
console that kubernetes is another one
of those um
uh at the moment it doesn't use this
form as the back end but i'm pretty sure
there was a meeting at google yesterday
that consisted of we should have that's
the back end
so so everything that's been going on
the doctor has been linux centric
because of scottsdale
and all that
in the future what
benefits could this have if
you move
so i think that like i'm really kind of
old so i remember things like solaris
zones which actually have you know like
um
actual security um
uh
my view of the world is that there's
there's a lot of customers for whom um
the thing they like about docker is the
workflow so it's really about um
they have troubleshipping code like it
is eighty for long sometimes we might
work in large organizations where it's a
long period of time between code gets
written code gets deployed there's a
bunch of things you just have to jump
through
docker's workflow is designed to sort of
streamline that and to some extent we
don't really care under the covers what
the platform you're streamlining on is
so if you thought about say like hyper v
support if loop container has a standard
api then it doesn't matter that's a
windows box running hyper-v underneath
but all it is is a computing shape like
the docker container and i should be
able to actually sort of move my code
around without me really caring what
that is and that also means you've
actually got to do multi-tenant
multi-operating system orchestration so
we're going to say this piece of this
application is a windows box running on
a hyper-v this piece over here is a
solaris box running in zones this piece
over here is a linux box running in a
lib container
i don't really care because
lip swarm and the api is doing all the
communication
can you write your own
security stack within
darker
one of the ideas behind the api
portability stuff is that the
plugability stuff will be that if you
want to um
we'll try and embed the hooks quite
deeply if you want to do stuff like if
somebody triggers this kernel capability
ux things like that so
i imagine that the trip wiry sort of
things will probably be the first thing
people do but but um
uh yeah there's lots of other ideas you
know if you want to also
build your own linux
container to the penetration testing can
you do it for something what i do is
i talk
darker and i put a kali linux
you should be able to as long as it's
got a
kernel recent enough to have the rest
capability i don't i'm not an operating
person i don't really care about what
distro you choose like i think you've
got an argument about whether
it's awesome that's right but all i care
about is that it actually makes runs
things and if it's got a 3.8 kernel or
later
out of the box
uh i'm not in an organization or company
that's like
at a small stage and
dunker just seems
really
awesome and i should adopt it but
what kind of compromises or risks am i
taking by adopting potentially like this
whole platform
if you can think of any i mean you're
selling it obviously
it's awesome you should give me money
right now
uh so i think the the obvious sort of
like it's not a true virtual machine
like it is it is it is
an operating system virtualization
uh that may be a concern for you um
you know our focus is really on that dev
sort of golden motion getting code out
of developers hands and as fast as the
other something you actually run it in
um
and that starts with that sort of build
test sort of stuff and then moves into
production um
i think that's probably the key thing i
would probably point out that it um
i think it's all the one the sort of
upsides of docker you know i can tell a
lot that's a lot of things but one thing
i will say to people is that it does
tend to force people to think about
their architecture a bit better docker's
really designed to run like a single
process or a single application in a
container so it forces you to think
about things like services
and and more people should build soa and
microservices architectures because
building monolithic architectures is
stupid and it's a pain in the ass
because i've been the guy who gets to
work on up at three o'clock in the
morning to debug the stupid application
and i don't want to do it anymore
microservices is very simple one service
it's either broken or it's not and talks
to another bunch of services you can see
where it's broken which service it's not
talking to um that sort of stuff is
awesome anything that encourages that
sort of architect yeah you should do it
more
um
lots of other things happy day i'm just
james at docker.com you can shoot me an
email i live locally happy to swing by
and
say yeah you can say stupid idea drawing
whiteboards
using um limo file to download the
containers
some of the containers that i approach
on my hub
darker
it's easy for me to get them some some
of them i don't get them where it
doesn't even give me
off the top of my head i'm not sure i
would recommend logging a ticket or
sending a note to the mail list um and
uh
if you
i'm j a m t t u r zero one get help with
you at me i will have a digger
if you reference me in the ticket i will
have a look
um i get lots of tickets but i will try
and have a switch tomorrow
is there a story for docker with windows
beyond hyper-v and i'm thinking more
like
kernel containerization drawbridge
things like that are you talking to
redmond about potentially tweaking the
the kernel itself too i don't know mark
russell or anybody like that and i would
not be having a conversation
it's
you know we're having similar
conversations with a bunch of people
it's hard for them to get their heads
around the idea um like traditional
virtualization is a very strong force
and people like that was not invented
here um but i think people are getting
the idea particularly developers are
like we will insist on having something
that works better than something that
takes five minutes yes you know um so
we're having some of those conversations
drawbridges
that might be a little bit further in
the future but um simple sort of window
support is something i would imagine
will appear at the start of next year
maybe depending how fast redmond moves
but
certainly dr support and azure you can
expect to see
like now
so i'm writing a book about docker
dockerbook.com
uh it is 95 finished i'm just doing
proofreading at the moment um it will be
out before the end of the month uh hang
on are we still in june
before the end of
um july i expect summer around the
middle of july assuming that uh my tech
reviews get back to me and i can fix all
my spelling mistakes
okay
you